also tonight it's yet another day
another round of january 6 committee
political theater of course this
predetermined outcome one-sided show
trial joining us now is the host of life
liberty levin i call him the great one
mark levin you know mark
you and i both condemn violence you and
i believe in protecting our institutions
protecting our elected officials we both
agree on that
uh we also agree what happened in the
summer of 2020 we had 574 riots mark
we had thousands of injured cops dozens
of dead americans and billions of
property damage
uh why are we also looking into that too
well we know why because this is a rogue
committee that is appointed by nancy
pelosi to stop donald trump from running
for president
you know uh donald trump apparently
waited 187 minutes uh sean before he
issued his video that would be 11 220
seconds
why do they keep saying 187 minutes like
anybody cares three hours and seven
minutes
and that shows dereliction of duty let
me tell you something
can they show us one damn sentence in
the hundreds of thousands of documents
that they have collected the thousand
witnesses they've had the text messages
the emails the documents anything
anywhere that links donald trump to
directing or ordering an attack on the
capitol building where is it
we're at hearing number eight where is
it you'd think they'd lead with it you'd
think with all the talk about
criminality they would show us
there's nothing absolutely zero evidence
that donald trump was involved in a in
an effort to violently overthrow our
elections or our government literally
nothing and the whole path has been
cleared for these people because it's a
pelosi stalinist investigation without
any barriers whatsoever now they talk
about 187 minutes before he released the
video
if you're leading an insurrection do you
release a video
while an insurrection quote unquote is
going on and say
please stand down or do you release a
video that says something a little
differently if you're leading an
insurrection like i'm calling on all my
armed supporters to go to the capitol
i'm calling on the united states
military i'm ordering them to arrest the
vice president to arrest members of
congress to encircle the building this
is an insurrection we're taking over the
government
none of that happened and yet that's an
insurrection not peacefully and
patriotically protest
not a video
187 minutes later that says
folks stand down you're supposed to be
peaceful and so forth
this entire hearing all it is is
innuendo it's opinion it's disgruntled
employees it's
it's it is a joke it's pathetic
so that's the kind of video that would
be released now
why are they doing this obviously
they're trying to damage trump they want
him to be indicted
even the reporters asked meritless
garland the parent-hating
republican legislature suing
open borders uh blind cop
asking him
well are you going to be able to
prosecute a former president the same
media pushing it like the russia
collusion the russian collusion you know
donald trump didn't use the department
of justice the fbi he didn't use the
intelligence agencies and unleash them
on biden like they were unleashed on
hundreds
against him by the uh by the obama
buying administration he didn't use the
blue chip law firms in washington dc
to uh launder money and come up with
these concoctions like uh
the dossier donald trump didn't do any
of that stuff
what else didn't donald trump do
regardless of what people said to him
did he call out the military did they
take the machines no
did he call out the personnel at dhs
and take the uh the drop boxes no did he
appoint a special counsel to oversee the
investigations no did he fire the acting
attorney general or deputy attorney
general no
he didn't do anything forgot whoa
he spoke to a governor he spoke to a
state legislature he suggested they send
alternative electors you're allowed to
do that
that's the politics that's the process
that's how it works he suggested that
the state legislatures may want to take
matters into their own hands right under
article two of the constitution it says
exactly that and in 2000 when we had a
rogue supreme court in florida that's
what the florida legislature was doing
but we have a corrupt politically
crooked attorney general corrupt
politically crooked u.s attorney how do
we know the cobra 9 are roaming free
and meanwhile 69 year old grandmother
who's getting cancer treatments were
just sentenced to 60 days in prison 60
days
now what's going on here well they want
trump to get indicted
but just in case he doesn't they're
looking at the 14th amendment of the
constitution america this is very
important
this is very important section 3 no
person shall be a senator or
representative in congress or electoral
president and vice president or hold any
office
civil or military
under the united states or under any
state who having previously taken an
oath as a member of congress or as an
officer in the united states or as a
member of any state legislature or as an
executive or judicial officer of any
state to support the constitution of the
united states shall have engaged in
insurrection
or rebellion against the same
why do you think they keep using the
word insurrection
this committee
democrats
the media keeps saying insurrection
dereliction of duty he led an
insurrection
he was thinking about leading an
insurrection he wrote about an
insurrection an insurrection it's
constant
why
because they're going to issue a report
regardless of what happens with the u.s
attorney the attorney general they're
going to point to the 14th amendment of
the constitution
they're going to point to the
insurrection clause and they're going to
claim that donald trump cannot run for
public office because he had a role in
the insurrection or he refused to stop
it
that is their game plan that's what's
going on and i've exposed these people
now it's time for the republicans to
push back
and reject the narrative
that's it i'm done
will they succeed yes or no
no
okay great one that's it i'm done now
you're really done all right don't
forget life liberty and levin number one
show on weekends sunday nights 8 p.m
right here on fox news hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else